hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on fortnight again for
another fortnight video the second one
of today and today we're gonna be
looking at some upcoming cosmetics found
in some of the game files that were
posted on reddit today so I thought I'd
share some of that info with you guys
maybe you could see some of the new
outfits coming in a future update so
let's get started it's real quick I just
want to shout out where this came from
on reddit shout out to YN ir z on reddit
i'll leave a link in the description
below if you want to look at it for
yourself it will also be on in the video
as well in form of images but if you
want to look for in the description for
your own pleasure go right ahead but
going off the first image it basically
shows six skins a kind of punk rock girl
with a leprechaun some type of dragon
lion wolf dog looking [ __ ] thing it
looks really damn sweet definitely gonna
pick that up some type of night girl
right next to her and then to very
probably going to be common skins
nothing too crazy just a fiddle face
paint on the one guy with a pink hat and
a little bit of a pink outfit for the
female overall amazing looking skins
definitely going to be picking up the
one in the middle there I still don't
know what that is whether that's a dog
or a lion either way looks absolutely
badass definitely gonna be picking it up
when it comes in the shop the second
image has four gliders and what I assume
are two back Billings I'm not entirely
sure about the guitar though but for the
gliders they do look really nice I see
one that has a type of punk rock style
in the middle portion that might fit
with the punk rock girl in the first
image a bit of spikes to match probably
the Ross Lorde outfit for the glider it
looks really nice has some engines on it
maybe some exhaust will come out of it
and then the one in the top right was
more like a racing car theme obviously
with the checkered pattern and then what
might what might possibly go with the
night female that we looked in the first
image something to match her set with
that glider overall these four gliders
are really nice probably and my personal
favorite would have to be the spiked one
in the top left but that's just me for
the back flings though this is
definitely going to be matching the punk
rock girl obviously there's the back
wing of a pink guitar and what might
look like a radio with some ammo
strapped to it I have no clue that is
all I know is that they just look really
nice next image we have two more back
links and then four pickaxes the two
back legs this one the one the first one
is going to be definitely matching the
knight female with three types of blades
coming out of adults really sweet to me
I love the interior I love
middle design of the middle of the
shield looks really well done as well as
a simple backpack with some shotgun
shells and what looks like a
walkie-talkie or radio on the side and
maybe a smoke grenade in the pocket I
can't entire I can't entirely tell but
it looks great nonetheless and for the
pickaxes we have a type of punk rock
theme which looks like a diamond belt
strapped around with spikes with a pink
type of handle where you would grip it
that's definitely going to fit for the
punk rock girl next one is a pickaxe
that looks like a sword with a dog
attached on it I'm assuming that's going
to fit for the dog type of lion outfit
that we saw in the first image of course
that's definitely going to pair well
together that looks really sweet and
then the last two one of them is a
leprechaun or is a leprechaun type theme
with a pot of gold going around the top
of the three leaf clover and what looks
like a green purple and blue kind of
spray-painted original pickaxe it looks
kind of nice to me but I would
definitely go with the Leprechaun one in
my personal opinion and then for the
last page we have this time what looks
like emotes now I'm not entirely sure
what any of these could be I do think
that the middle one the one at the top
is the John Travolta type meme where
he's got the coat over his arm and he's
kind of looking around all confused and
stuff I think that's what might that's
going to be in terms of the other emotes
I have know it like no clue at all the
bottom right one looks like it's going
to be a dance the bottom left look it
looks like it might be just a simple
pointing who knows I think the top
rights gonna be a little like shrug off
the shoulders kind of like wipe the dirt
off your shoulder and then I have
absolutely no idea what the guy is doing
in the top left of that image but either
way these are going to be amazing
whenever these happen to drop those are
the upcoming cosmetics that we found
that someone found in the game files
like I said shout out to the guy on
reddit why and irz appreciate you
posting that like I said this script
it'll be in the description if you want
to check that out for yourself but
anyway guys that's going to be the end
of the video today like the V if you
guys did enjoy really does help me out
subscriber for new I'm gonna start
covering a lot more leak stuff with for
tonight and stuff like guides and tips
and other types like the weekly
challenges video I just did before my
recent video is going to be on screen
like I said it was the week three
challenges I covered where the bullseye
locations are and where the trap where
the treasure map is near snobby shores
so definitely want to check that out if
you guys are having trouble with that I
know I was that's why I made the video
in the first place
but like I said that's going to be the
end and what that guys hope you have a
great
today I hope you enjoyed and peace out